so we talked about just kind of using
this last a little bit of time to
reflect together on coming together I
actually thought this had occurred
before so first question I'd ask julie
is how often have you done this is
the first time I've ever done it so
obviously the first question to be
thinking about is this really a useful
gathering is this allowing something to
happen that would not have happened
otherwise and what way is this a useful
element of of the process I think Julie
tried to give a bit of an overview at
the beginning today of the processes
that are in place now to school some of
the structures that have come into play
at the Institute just reading the last
year or two some of them are quite new
to my knowledge so but the really point
key point here is you guys do the work
so you're the ones who've been here all
day but not just here all day you're
deeply immersed in doing a different
facets of this as I've gotten to know
Julie and talk to her about this
particular day there's like two ideas
that have come back again and again and
again one is a the title of the day you
know how does MIT become a game changer
and the second is how do we do it
together how do we build a different
sense of community connection working
together it's very easy and it's very
natural in not just MIT but any academic
environment too quickly everybody goes
off into their respective lab or
classroom and does all sorts of
wonderful things but there's no real
sense of doing it together and
consequently a lot of lost synergies
opportunities and maybe even completely
lost ideas it could be key for being
game changer so I just want to kind of
open it up a little bit and see anybody
have any reflections for the day as
those of you again doing the work as you
SAT here and listened in either of those
two areas or best yet combining the two
what really stands out for you is the
opportunities for MIT as a game changer
and doing it or together I think that
one of the things I'm Jeremy Gregory I'm
in the civil and environmental
engineering department and the executive
director that concrete stain ability hub
and in some of the work that we do what
we found is that you know trying to
tackle a particular topic and then
asking people basically you know what
would you do to solve this problem
rather than being prescriptive about the
the solutions just saying this is what
we're trying to do and then what MIT
does best is innovate then and some of
the earlier discussions we had actually
was about four for some ideas basically
opening it up to this this hackathon was
the the the idea that we came up with
earlier but i think that's that's the
kind of thing where MIT excels you know
not being prescriptive about solutions
just saying this is the problem how do
we innovate and get the people together
and motivate them to actually try and
try and solve it one of the things that
I thought was compelling about today's
discussion I think she's already gone
the student that was in our group this
morning really thought that changing
behavior was important it's not just
about what we build and how we build it
it's about how people operate the spaces
that they're in so teaching people at a
younger a younger age for example she
was talking about having to be a core
requirement class for students coming in
really helps develop new behaviors so
that somebody who's so focused on the
work that they're doing isn't so focused
that they're not thinking about oh I
don't have to have three sashes of fume
hoods open or I could have turned the
lights off in that office when I walked
out or something like that and so it's a
little bit about changing behavior and I
thought that was a good point that she
made this morning one thing that really
struck me in the conversations
especially this morning was everyone's
willingness and interest on having a
more transparent and collaborative
working environment I was really
surprised by that it's something that I
work on every day and I know of another
some other initiatives in MIT that are
doing that but to hear three different
groups in the working groups this
morning say that that's what they wanted
they wanted hackathons they want
innovation but they want it to be open
for everyone to participate that was
really surprising and inspiring for me
especially because in traditional
academia it's very compelling to keep
things really closed
and to succeed in their own projects and
not necessarily work across borders but
that's what we're all interested in
doing one of the things that I think is
extraordinary about MIT is the way that
we can cut across diversity of schools
and diversity of stakeholders and I
think that we've had great
representation here today of a real
diversity of staff we've had faculty
here we've had students here we've
mentioned alumni I would love to see us
be able to have a more robust engagement
across those four constituencies of the
MIT campus because they are all invested
and implicated and important for our
success in moving forward so I think
that it as we're reflecting on today as
a opportunity to connect on
sustainability I think that we've got
some some real successes there and I
think we also have room to grow so
today's was a lot of preaching to the
choir because we are the choir a lot of
us are invested either in what we do or
what we study or what are what we teach
in terms of some aspect of
sustainability or another but we've
never gotten all together and so the
choir needs the same sheet of music to
use and so today went a long way toward
all of us having a common understanding
what sustainability means to MIT and I
think as we leave here we need to use
that sheet of music that we've all
worked on today so like I said forgive
the amount of metaphors amusing you know
we do have a lot of things going on that
are similar to sustainability and that
we're trying to study them from a lot of
different angles it's only a piece of a
lot of people's jobs and then there are
a few people for whom it's their entire
job and so I'm thinking about wellness
as something going on on campus and I
see Howard over there and I not sure who
else might be here but you know what I
think about what we're trying to do for
our community in terms of wellness I
think there may be some synergies there
and sustainability of course could fall
into that category and I think there may
be other things as well if we think
about them where perhaps at birch
injures work in terms of community
development equity and community
development so I think we
ought to think about where there are
connections between things that cut
across the entire campus and how how as
a community we need to approach those
I'm struck from the day sessions about
the number of times and the frequency of
people's desire for better for data and
metadata to educate to make decisions to
learn but this dichotomy about the
competency that we individually or as a
group may have in collecting
understanding deciding and using that
data in a way that is knowledgeable and
I think there is this this chasm between
our need for better understanding of the
decisions that we need to make and our
lack of competency or understanding of
the best ways to take advantage of that
value just had one thought and we have
to be careful that this and become
another technical fix because certainly
one of the themes I've heard a lot is
recognizing that there's an immense
array of of complex technical issues but
that game changing eyes and about the
house only it includes those but it's
really about how an institution moves I
just want to add one additional thought
something else I picked up from Julie
who I've talked with them numerous
occasions not just for for this and it
relates to what you were saying about I
mean I'm always sensitive to words the
word sustainability which 25 years ago
was really not in use at all suddenly is
now used everywhere and it means a
million different things and and I think
that if you're doing something that's
really important you have to be able to
use different types of words Julie said
something which I thought was a slightly
different frame but very interesting for
all of us to ponder she said for me this
whole effort is about capacity building
she said something to this effect you
sell a while ago to building the
capacity of an institution to deal with
truly complex issues
so that's a little different way to
frame it obviously there are kind of no
more iconic complex issues in our world
today in poverty destruction of
ecosystems climate destabilization and
that's the kind of issues that would
mostly get under that umbrella of
sustainability but I think that as you
were saying why what's wrong with also
seeing wellness in the health and
well-being of the community a place like
MIT as part of what we're focused on I
think you're absolutely right and if you
think about it the way Julie said it
building the capacity of an institution
to deal with truly complex issues the
sort that fall between the cracks or
people work on and work on a workout and
never really make much headway is
wonderful kind of overall frame for me
and one last thing i just thought i'd
like to share as i've heard it expressed
in a couple different ways I'm unlike
you I spend most my time at other places
not doing the kind of work you guys do
here at MIT but it's the same kind of
work and I watched many organizations on
their journeys you know first to get
some traction I mean these issues are so
big it's easy for people to go it's
impossible and in all invariably they
start with energy efficiency waste
reduction stuff that they can measure
and make a business case for it's very
understandable you got to take a first
step and foremost institutions those are
the kind of first steps but relatively a
large percentage kind of gets stuck
there you know they never get much
beyond you know the proverbial metaphor
we always use in the organization change
field was the low-hanging fruit the
things for which you if you just get
your act together by golly you can do a
lot and again they're compelling and
they're measurable and you have a pretty
direct to the bottom line impact my
primary conclusion from watching many
many institutions mostly in the business
sector get beyond being stuck with the
relatively easy things is it eventually
becomes part of their DNA
find a way to connect and it's different
for everyone because you might say the
institutional DNA that kind of core
cultural DNA of every institution is
unique as it is for every person and so
to me the big question here on being
game changer and doing it together kind
of loops back to I like the way was
Fraser what's unique to MIT I
appreciated the debris but well let's
not get so caught up and being unique
that's fair enough but if you think
about what is it that really defines who
we are that would naturally generate
energy would naturally foster more and
more integration more and more
internalization more and more real scale
and you are an institution like MIT that
it would always start with a very simple
point you know how does this core how is
this however we define this core to our
educational mission how is it core to
our research mission and I think for MIT
it has to be both business is not just
an educational institution and the
synergy between what we do as
researchers and what we do as teachers
is really right at the core to me of
what makes MIT really a great
institution it's not unique many
institutions could claim that but then
when you dig into that you find a lot of
pretty unique or idiosyncratic features
so how does it affect the students and
how does it as allow us to kind of bring
our research I was playing with all
kinds of funny images in my head we got
all sorts always always have great
people doing research individually but
if we keep that idea of collectively you
might say well wouldn't it be cool if
anybody doing anything that was
pertinent to any of these issues in any
of their research processes had a way of
making that visible to the community as
a whole so we could say oh we could use
that or we could use that over here or
that person is done a lot of similar
work why don't we go and talk to them
about what we're trying to do so how to
make the research accessible that's a
question that in many ways of course
many of us deal with all the time in our
increasingly interconnected you know
web-enabled world but I just wouldn't
lose sight of the impact on this
stew because I famiy one of the criteria
be don't do anything that doesn't
involve students in some meaningful way
and there's where I think one of the
idiosyncratic features of MIT would
naturally come into play and I'm just
saying something that I've heard several
people say the hands-on nature of
education I've always thought that the
labs were the kind of the archetype of
what MIT is all about because labs were
not just a bar where the research was
done the lab was where the uniqueness of
the MIT education experience occurred so
don't do anything doesn't involve the
students think about how it connects to
the research and educational mission
thank you so much Peter